what what was unique about his
personality like you know for somebody
to say you know from washing windows to
doing this and you know if you got a
headache here's how to get rid of a
headache and you hit your you know you
kind of gradually go through this and I
if you're going through this party
you're going everything had a system to
it on on what he wrote about and how
many phds he had and how many degrees he
had and the controversy behind the
degrees that he had we didn't have any
what I mean there is two stories you
hear about you hear about the amount he
has and you hear about he had none but
but the truth is he had none he flunked
out of George Washington University he
did not finish
um there okay you ask about haban habad
was a larger than life character a
storyteller
if there is one word I would use to
describe Hubbard it's storyteller
bullshitter that could be another one
but Storyteller is the more sort of
appropriate because his history in life
was writing fiction he was a fiction
writer a Pulp Fiction writer he
developed a skill of
presenting
stories to people a very entertaining
and those many of those stories about
are about himself and many of them are
completely and utterly untrue
and he developed a sort of a persona for
himself as a war hero and a like all
these things that actually
are not true he then
um at the end of the war he was in the
U.S Navy he had a very in
indistinguished career in the United
States Navy despite the fact he
subsequently claimed that he was a war
hero he had purple hearts he was injured
he was a ship captain he was this he was
that like the stories of his exploits in
World War II uh you know should be the
subject of a movie if any of them were
true but they're not so he Then Came
Upon This thing of I'm going to cure
myself of the injuries he claimed he was
blinded and crippled at the end of the
war he was neither he had ulcers and he
developed this thing called Dianetics
and Dianetics he claims is
scientifically researched and tested on
hundreds of people and this and that
none of that is true
yes he he dabbled around with people but
Dianetics is is basically
regression therapy it is taking an
incident of of upset or emotional strain
or physical injury or whatever and going
back and finding the first point that it
began and sort of recounting it and
Hubbard
devised invented created this thing that
he called the reactive mind and that is
what Dianetics is about and the reactive
mind is a one of Hubbard's great Strokes
of Genius he said that you have a
subconscious mind that is
controls your emotions makes you sick
gives you physical ailments and that it
is
it is composed of moments of pain and
unconsciousness that are below your
level of awareness and the current
things in the environment will trigger
your historical subconscious thoughts
pains and emotions and that Dianetics
can solve that
the beauty of this to present to someone
is look you may be really [ __ ] up but
it's not your fault
so this thing called a reactive mind
and you don't control it but we have a
way of getting rid of it and if you give
me some money
I will teach you an audit that's what
it's called auditing in Scientology and
get rid of your reactive mind
now
someone who has physical illnesses or
who is traumatized or who is emotionally
unstable or whatever telling them that
you've got this secret that you have
discovered that nobody else has ever
known and that that I can cure you of
those things I mean Hubbard's claim
still sold in the Dianetics book today
it'll cure cancer it'll cure bursitis
you'll throw away your glasses you won't
need a walking cane anymore you won't be
irrational you'll be a perfect thinking
machine none of these things prove to be
true at all
um well okay here's the trick of this
Patrick there is
some placebo effect that you tell
someone I'm going to cure you and then
you do stuff and they pay for it a lot
of people will say yes I'm cured oh yes
I can walk again it's like
you so you can't exactly say that
nothing ever happens to anybody and this
is one of the things that's very tricky
about this subject is you will see all
sorts of testimony from people telling
and saying oh my God I I were I was such
a nervous wreck and now I'm not and oh
my God I had this I had this terrible
problem with nausea or when I woke up in
the morning and I found through
Dianetics that I was solved now and
I guess that probably is true but that
is presented by Scientology now or Hub
then as if you do it exactly as Hubbard
says it works 100 of the time absolutely
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]